hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and my name is Rachel T's missus
Tamara's never seen the special guest
rachel t yeah every time we're together
we're like oh we're gonna do one of
these episodes and we do never do her we
talk to other things we were talking
with Doug Walker about what movie we
should do and it came up that neither of
us has seen Mamma Mia
what it okay what did you think Mamma
Mia was gonna be going into it you know
I thought like well maybe you maybe the
musical numbers will be good because
that'll that'll make a terrible script
okay mm-hmm I thought that the cast was
so good that liked it there was no way
it was gonna be as bad as Doug and Rob
Walker say yeah yeah yeah sometimes you
know they and we have different tastes
we like musicals do you like Moulin
Rouge I love my love I even like the bad
movie musicals like I loved Phantom of
the Opera growing up oh yeah I mean
Jesus Christ Superstar oh my god 70s
Jesus Christ Superstar he's good it's so
good
they're just screaming for Jesus
screaming literally screaming for geez
Italy so yeah I think I was expecting
that just just at least fun I guess
we'll get into it will you snap with me
yeah one two
[Music]
mama meat that's a review bad bad I need
a tie notes there's this giant here's a
baby no that's a big one movie stop no
movie stop it didn't stop no no and I
know that this is a story that was
already in existence did they take away
from this because you've seen the stage
version actually happened oh I wanted to
go see it when it was in my town and I
couldn't get a ticket because it was
sold out
everyone loves Mamma Mia and the second
movie came out which I did see for
chairmanships aw I didn't love it but
all the reviews were like glowing for it
and I was like oh I didn't love excited
to see the first I guess ya know first
thing I want to talk about is how you
don't get to know Amanda Seyfried fiance
at all oh he's the worst like their
first scene is gonna think he's like
saying hi to her friends and she's like
get out and leave it yikes
Wow maybe don't get married to her and
then like the second time you see him
he's singing about how jealous he gets
of her yeah with the three old men wait
which doubt but we'll go that's a whole
other mother and then the relationships
between the young three friends and the
older three friends is just 100%
screaming that's it I mean that's all
women do right when I've seen it they
just scream yeah I mean when they're
excited
not even just like wouldn't I see a
friend for the first time in a long time
it's like just 24/7 we're really we're
straining ourselves right now yeah
[Music]
it's gonna be the first time that we're
glad that the mic is clipping anytime
the girls would all be screaming at each
other there would be like four Greek
people in the back just looking at him
like the like doing Bob on the boat yeah
this is what boat people do cranking
something yeah so their relationships
were not well developed they just like
wanted you to think that they were
because of how much screaming payday I'm
clearly excited to see each other well I
mean to be fair the three younger
friends gave us a lot of context when
they first when they first read I the
tall one I'm the tough one and I'm tiny
why would you choose that as your I know
they're all trying to get T names but
that's so sad to me to think about
describing yourself as just tiny that's
it that's all you have going for you
like that's your legacy that's your
personality I sure I'm dull I'm tough
the writing didn't put anything that was
tough in her character yeah there was
nothing that was tough I feel like the
actors knew that they were in a bad
movie and just gave us especially Meryl
she had this weird voice that she was
doing not her singing which was a whole
other thing but her place speaking voice
was this weird growl like we're like Oh
Here I am tough girl who does tools I
have power tools and I drink during the
day but which also constantly drunk
everyone was constantly drunk there
wasted the whole movie big 20-18 mood I
get it but listen keep them there to my
own I guess it makes me feel a little
better to see someone like Meryl Streep
do something horrible yeah yeah that
makes it yeah you know you can't win
them all hmm she's human after all
Pierce Brosnan was just a special little
delight of a vocalist team fun
yeah James Bond he can do a lot of
things very very well and I would say
singing did give his best though - every
time you were singing if you give like
this smolder I write
Mamma Mia yeah very attractive like so I
gave him a pass right if you're pretty
you're fine it's why I could get the
pastor that wreath always so okay just a
little catch up in the second one Meryl
Streep is dead she doesn't die in this
one cuz that's when I saw the second I
was like oh she wants to die at the end
that's very extreme I don't remember
that in any of the tellings but cool
cool cool so she doesn't die in the
first one and so in the second one she's
just she has died now she's not that old
and like if they don't really say why
maybe they did I wasn't listening this
story is so poorly done like in this I
guess I'm sure it's in the musical - but
she marries Pierce Brosnan's character
I'm nothing to make this day about me
it's not my daughter and then the
downside you did I don't wanna get
married she's like cool well I'll just
take up the wedding and you don't give
me any context that she likes him the
best so it's kind of just like cheap sex
yeah maybe if she died at the end it
would have made it more interesting like
yeah I would have actually felt
something for the characters I did not
at one point we completely missed I
think a big story arc because we were
all having Ike's head there were four of
us watching and I looked back at the TV
and somebody said a very dramatic line
and I was like wait what happened and
one by one every was like oh I was
looking like I don't even think we were
rounded to check
I also okay to the musical numbers they
were so poorly choreographed right
they're like going like this in the
background and like break down this
musical Josh that for you
if the script is bad but the music is
good people still like the show they
come see the music good singing good
dance numbers they were like at is fine
it'll get us through right I think the
cast is good that'll get it yeah she's
Meryl is a great actress she'll be fine
knowing but you know there's only so
much you can do with the bad script what
I would love to hear is that Meryl had
the time of her life filming this there
in paradise she's just like around with
ABBA music and like she knows it's gonna
be bad so she's just having a fun time
with it I hope she was drunk the whole
time
me too oh man oh we just want the best a
a ballad during the wedding and then she
goes back up to join it everyone's like
yeah how'd your belly go she's supposed
to walk her down the aisle and hello
there and she's just singing a ballad on
a cliff like Meryl you're your baby
pretty so selfish Oh B uh-huh uh-huh a
lot of you that doesn't translate very
well into acting poor it started off and
Amanda Seyfried was trying her darndest
to just act her little heart out and or
big heart I don't know I just said that
kind of condescendingly but she it's
like singing this song and there's a lot
of ojas that she has to vocalize and
that's so awkward
you know something that people do yeah
I'm gonna start after seeing this for me
obviously at a point you can't act that
hard no no in a song no you know her
voice is pretty good in this she's
sounding good I
really really enjoy her in a lot of
things too I think like I said the cast
was really good I think they all had a
meeting the night before filming started
and we're like did you read the script
I didn't read it my bed read it's a
classical music I would like fine it's
gonna be great yeah I can't wait yeah
but maybe we should take a shot not
wasted they showed up to film and
they're like all of the the three the
trio of all their ladies all of their
songs were taken like completely down
the up oh my gosh yes oh no I don't know
is that the original right though yeah
like no way definitely okay
they're like harmonizing you just love
what will be your word if you had to
choose one word huh you're I'm a blank
one yeah I'm the diabetic one that's my
personality
it would probably just still be that's
all one oh technology Internet if he
were that's not I know this movie was
made in wet 2004 five six in there it
wasn't funny then it's never gonna be
funny and you know it's gonna date it
you only know the Internet's getting
bigger you know that's gonna date your
movie you also know that's not in Mamma
Mia the musical don't put that in there
I hope it's not all the comments are
gonna be like you wrong chair you out
stop movie stopped hammer attack stop
camera it was a beautiful location
mm-hmm the shots were really pretty the
lighting was really well done it looked
great
we were joking like the cinematographer
showed up from time
it's but people really seem to like it
yeah I have talked to people who love it
for us at least it's because we are
musical theater people
and and we also love a lot of these
actors and so it's just a weird thing to
see something that should be good with
people who should be good and then that
kind of it worked
thank you so much for joining me of
course I believe you know I'm so happy
there's so many movies that both of us
haven't seen so much all of them we had
a plethora to choose yeah yeah well I
will see you all next week
happy new year thank you for watching my
I'm the tall one I'm the top we're not a
part of it just scream to me actually
when he wants
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you